we are now seeing the lowest growth of
trade and a very very weak investment
growth and that is at least partly
partly responsible for the very anemic
growth of the whole of the world economy
than we see today very weak
growth of trade and very weak growth of
investment because of the uncertainties
we have not been able to detonate
investment which is tomorrow's scene of
growth the strong NATO is of course good
for Europe but it's also good for the
United States I spoke with the
president-elect John Trump after he was
elected and he conveyed a very clear
message to me and to the whole Alliance
that he and the United States will stay
strongly committed to NATO and that has
also been the message from the man he
has nominated as the new sector of
Defence and the new sector of state I've
been very troubled by the attitude of
businesspeople from the United States
here in Davos people who two three
months ago were saying he was a man they
would never do business with are today
hailing him as a great economic
statesman continue professor but he's a
hundred percent right it has been
stunning we have built a world over
since the post war that is incredibly
interlinked as we are seeing now in the
complications around brexit undoing that
is a very complicated process there are
many ways you can go about trade look
there's no question that the global
trading system is not entirely fair it's
certainly not free there are many
unleveled sort of playing field issues
now you can go about this in two ways
you can react by putting up barriers or
I can work to break down barriers on the
other side
[Music]